en el mundo vivió una jornada de
protestas en la que según reportes
oficiales cerca de 4000 personas
salieron a las calles para manifestarse
en contra de las restricciones que rigen
actualmente en la ciudad por el rebrote
de la variante delta de kobe 19 dicen
quienes protestan que están cansados de
los constantes y estrictos
confinamientos 218 personas fueron
arrestadas y seis policías fueron
hospitalizados tras resultar heridos en
medio de enfrentamientos físicos con los
manifestantes estos actos violentos y
alteraciones del orden público se dieron
en el centro de la capital del estado de
victoria melbourne está viviendo su
sexto confinamiento y el cuarto este año
por la pandemia de hecho la ciudad esta
semana completó 200 días acumulados en
confinamiento desde que empezó la
pandemia por kobe 19 en marzo de 2020 ha
dicho el gobierno federal de australia
que la única solución a estos
confinamientos es aumentar los niveles
de vacunación australia se acerca al 30
por ciento de su población mayor de 16
años vacunada con ambas dosis de
astrazéneca y fire 1 de cada 2
australianos ya recibió su primera dosis
vacunas se han suministrado 16 millones
de vacunas en este país que tiene 25
millones de habitantes en sídney
brisbane y perth también hubo
manifestaciones en contra de las
restricciones